My inflammation is not going away. I don't eat gluten or dairy and very little sugar.
Christmas time I had cookies, inflammation started. That could 10 weeks it went away, but
at Easter I had a few cookies, inflammation came back again, but went away. The inflammation
came back, but I don't know why. I hope you could help. The only thing I could think of is
I had some rice. Okay, so inflammation can be caused by a food sensitivity. So if I have antibodies
to liate it, liate in peptides, that's peptides of gluten or casein peptides and you eat
casein or gluten, then you're going to cause this ramped up inflammation. So if you have
that take place, you have to eliminate gluten or dairy or goals from the diet. The best
way to know that you have food sensitivities is to do a test. The Syrex lab is the best test
for food sensitivities because not only do they measure the whole protein because you get
food sensitivities to food proteins. So, but more specifically, you get food sensitivities
to portions of food proteins. That is called a peptide. So creatin is the protein in gluten.
Well, creatin breaks down into numerous different peptides. Those peptides can cross a damaged
gut wall. If they cross a damaged gut wall, you can start to develop through your B cells
part of your immune response. You'll develop antibodies to that peptide. So now every time
you eat gluten, you fire this immune reaction. That's called a gluten sensitivity or gluten
allergy. That's not celiac. That's called a gluten allergy. This can happen to any food
that you eat. So let's say if I'm eliminating dairy and gluten from my diet, but so I'm eating
a cookie that doesn't have, it's gluten free. And I can't figure out why I reacted to it.
You could react to some other thing. You can get a gluten free flower mix. There's lots
of different gluten free flower mixes on the market. I have no idea what it is that you're
reacted to. Nobody does. You'd only be guessing. That's why you do a test. So Syrex labs
has their array 3X, their array 4 that measure gluten and all its peptides, including the
array 4, all of those across reactive foods. Or if you want to get real serious, you also
run array 10, which measures 180 different foods in their peptides, cooked in raw. That's the
very important thing with Syrex. They test both cooked in raw peptides, which is really important,
because you're not just eating raw food, you're eating cooked carrots too. So that's the way you'd
find out what it is that is causing inflammation. Have some videos on that that you could look at
as well. So if you go to our YouTube channel, I just uploaded several videos on Syrex testing,